Was ist das für ein Name? Woher kommt das denn?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Aus der Türkei?
Ja.
Können dort Frauen auch studieren?
dürfen Frauen studieren?
Natürlich, natürlich.
Wir haben viele Möglichkeiten dafür.
Das sind ja aber eine Ausnahme.
Die Türken, die hier kennen, sind ganz schlimm.
Sind immer Frauenfeindlich.
Aber okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Sie verstehen das?
Können Sie mich, wenn ich so spreche?
Ich verstehe sie ganz gut jetzt.
Aber wenn ich nicht verstehe, natürlich frage ich sie wieder nach.
Okay, gut.
Ja, erst werde ich Ihre persönliche Darsteller aufnehmen.
Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheid.
Dann geht es nicht schneller Frau Doktor.
Sie haben doch schon meine Daten.
Was wollen Sie denn schon wieder?
Ja, ich meine zum Beispiel Ihre Name, Vorname und Geburtstatum.
Ich brauche.
Da habe ich mich doch schon vorangemeldet.
Ja, ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber ich brauche diese Daten für ganz Unterlagen.
Ja, dann fragen wir die Krankenschwester davon.
Meine Güte, ist das hier ein schlimmes Krankenhaus?
Ja, das ist ein schlimmes Krankenhaus.
Ich komme, weil ich Sorgen und Beschwerden habe.
Sie fragen mich nach meinem Namen.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Ich habe wieder Vorname und Geburtstatum gezeigt.
Ja, ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber ich brauche dennoch.
Dann erfahrt es.
Mein Name ist Friedrich Hans Udo Fischer.
Udo Fischer.
Ich habe wieder Vorname und Geburtstatum.
Ich habe wieder Nachname und Geburtstatum.
Fischer, wieder Fischer.
Ja.
Fischer, mit ER am Ende bitte.
Fischer.
Das ist ein bekannte deutscher Name.
Okay.
Herr Fischer, wie alt bist du?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Und wann ist die Genagebührung?
Das ist auch noch mein Geburtstatum.
Meine Güte.
28. Juli.
Ja.
1905.
Okay.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie denn?
Ne, 50, 50, muss ich sagen, oder?
Ich bin 1,75 m.
75 Jahre alt.
Und wie viel wiegt man Sie?
Das sind Sie genau.
Mein Gewicht ist ungefähr 102 kg.
Und das ist so weit.
Okay.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Fischer?
Was für Besprayer haben Sie?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie mir wirklich helfen können.
Aber ich versuche ja.
Langsam fange ich an Sie zum Müllgen, Frau Doktor.
Sie machen einen netten Eindruck.
Also erzähle ich Ihnen meine Sorgen.
Ich habe seit 3 Wochen ungefähr.
Schmerzen im Bereich meines Rückens.
Im länden Wirbelbereich.
Und das geht über die Po-Backe bis zu den Beinen.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Okay.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
So schlimm.
Ich glaube, die Schmerzen in den Beinen.
Ja, bei den Seiten.
Die Schmerzen sind manchmal so stark,
dass ich nicht richtig laufen kann,
dass ich manchmal auch nachzuwach werde.
Und das hatte ich vor.
Ich glaube, die Schmerzen sind nur Bewegung.
Auf oder?
Mal bei Bewegung.
Mal kommen Sie auch spontan.
Und ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Mein Haushalt kommt da nicht weiter.
Der Orthopäde wusste auch nichts.
Okay.
Können Sie nichts.
Die Ärzte wissen Sie, verstehen auch nicht mehr.
Früher waren die Ärzte viel besser.
Früher war alles viel besser.
Viel besser.
Ich habe gerade den gesagt, Frau Doktor.
Deswegen bin ich ja da.
Die Schmerzen wären schmackig.
Das hilft nichts.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind sie eher dunf, oder stechend?
Oder?
Die Ärzte sind halt da, die Schmerzen.
Manchmal führt es zu Verkramfung der Muskulatur.
Manchmal ist es dumpf.
Aber irgendwie sind die Schmerzen halt da.
Und das wird immer mehr.
Auf einer Schmerzskala, wobei ein sehr leichter,
aber sensierter Stahl ist, wie bewahrten Sie es?
Ich würde mal sagen, manchmal sogar bis 7, 8.
Das ist eine sehr große Schmerzskala.
Manchmal ist es sehr schwer.
Manchmal ist es sogar bis 7, 8.
Auch nicht nur an den Beinen,
sondern manchmal merke ich das auch an den Rücken.
Oder an den Armen auf.
Okay, beiden Armen oder?
Ja, mal in dem anderen Arm.
Das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Okay, ich bringe die Schmerzen von Bein zu Bein
oder von Arm zu Bein.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Manchmal sind Sie immer da,
an allen Extremitäten,
manchmal nur an einer Seite.
Das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie auch Gelenkschmerzen?
Auch, ja.
Auf welchem Gelenkschmerz
haben Sie auch Gelenkschmerzen?
Überall, mal sind Sie auf der Schulter,
dann ist es an den Händen.
Manchmal ist es einfach an der Hüfte.
Immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen?
Besonderes morgens oder gibt es bestimmte?
Ja, ich habe es immer aufgefahren.
Es ist mal am Tag, mal in der Nacht.
Da ist man aufgefahren, aber es wird immer mehr.
Das fällt mir auf.
Haben Sie auch Gelenkschmerzen bemerkt?
Nein.
Leiden Sie auch unter Kopfschmerzen?
Manchmal.
Wenn ich mir das Weltpolitik angucke,
dann habe ich keine Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Leider.
Du hast die Viktation alles anstellen, meine Güte.
Aber ansonsten,
wenn Sie mich zur Frage haben, habe ich keine Kopfschmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe jetzt.
Wie fühlen Sie sich im Allgemeinen?
Ich meine, haben Sie
depressive Stimmung oder?
Was?
Ich bin doch nicht verrückt, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin doch nicht blöd, ich habe keine Depression. Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie an Ihren Beinen
oder an Ihren Armen Krippen
oder Taubheit, Gefühl oder Kraftlosigkeit bemerkt?
Ja, so kraftlos.
Ich werde dich dann schon manchmal.
Das stimmt.
Ich habe keine Taubheit.
Okay.
Haben Sie Haupferlbeänderung?
Haupferlbeänderung?
Ja.
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber oder hatten Sie schon einmal?
Ich habe hier nicht aufgefallen.
Fieber hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Denken Sie,
dafür gibt es bestimmte Ausgöse
für die Schmerzen.
Ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Es geht jetzt seit circa 3 Monaten.
Davor hatte ich so etwas nicht.
Ich meinte vielleicht hatten Sie
einen Unfall oder etwas
nicht gemacht.
Nicht, dass Sie wüssten, ich arbeite gerne im Garten,
aber das mache ich immer.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Angehung verloren?
Nein.
Oder haben Sie zugenommen? Nein.
Nein, nein, das ist immer ungefähr gleich.
Okay. Wisst Ihr Appetit?
Leider zu gut.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen
oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, bisher klappt es eigentlich ganz gut.
Wir haben mit dem Wasserlassen,
das ist so wie bei Männern,
dass ich nachts öfters zum Wasserlassen aufstehen muss.
Aber da war ich beim Urloben.
Okay.
Und haben Sie
momentan auch weitere Beschwerden?
Als ich habe andere Erkrankungen,
wie Bluthochdruck?
Nein, ich meinte aktuelle Beschwerden.
Leiden Sie momentan an
ganz weichem Beschwerden auch.
Nein, das reicht ja letztendlich.
Ja, das reicht, aber ich muss genau fragen.
Andere Erkrankungen,
weswegen ich Tabletten nehme.
Ich dachte, Sie fragen nach danach.
Okay. Leiden Sie
einen Event-Passion vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe hohen Bluthoch.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ach, das geht schon seit über 20 Jahren.
Ich habe hohe Scholesterin.
Und ich hatte vor 3 Jahren mal
einen Herz-Catheter.
Weil meine Herzerkrankung,
beziehungsweise mein Herz,
oder die Gefäße, ich weiß nicht genau,
verkalzt hat mein Arzt gesagt.
Seitdem habe ich Medikamente.
Ich habe eine andere Erkrankung.
Und seitdem nehme ich Medikamente.
Ich habe eine Stadt.
Wie bitte?
Was ist Stadt?
Haben Sie leider jetzt nicht verstanden, Frau Doktor?
Ja, wegen der Vergundung
könnte ich leider auch sie nicht gut verstehen.
Genau.
Also jetzt versuch ich nochmal, was da meinten Sie?
Ein Stent.
Ja, ja, ich meinte Stent.
Das ist eine gute Duschblutung
Ihrer Herzgefäße mit einer kleinen Röhrchen.
Ich habe ein Herz-Catheter bekommen
und da hat man auch einen Stent gelegt.
Was nehmen Sie als Medikament
regelmäßig ein?
Also ich hatte,
meine Kardäologie hat jetzt auch Medikamente umgestellt.
Jetzt muss ich gucken in meine Liste.
Jetzt muss ich meine Liste raus.
Hier habe ich Amnodipin, 5 Milligramm.
Ja, nur einmal.
Nur einmal, genau.
Und dann nehme ich hier Metoprol, 50.
Und abends.
Morgen, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr, Uhr,
und abends.
Morgen und Abend.
Dann habe ich hier,
wie heißt das?
Kann des Satan?
Kann des Satan? 16 Milligramm?
16.
Und da haben wir neue Kondesterin-Tanbetten bekommen.
Kann das nur abends?
Nur abends, ja.
Und die Atovastatin,
das sind jetzt die neuen Kondesterin-Tanbetten.
Da habe ich 80 Milligramm bekommen.
80.
Okay.
Nur abends, oder?
Die nehme ich nur abends, ja.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich die Kondesterin-Tanbetten.
Und diese Kandesatan,
das habe ich vor 4 Monaten ungefähr.
Früher, was haben Sie eingenommen?
Oh ja, wir hießen das.
Ich glaube, das ist Ram-Mipril.
Und ich hatte noch etwas anderes für das Kondesterin.
Ich glaube, das hieß irgendwie,
so etwas wie Simva oder so ähnlich.
Das hat mein Kondologe geändert.
Okay.
Ja, lesz-te-me-ti-comante, können-s-te wiederholen?
Simva.
Simva-Statin war das, glaube ich, und Ram-Mipril.
Okay, mein Karstranden.
Ja, wurden Sie außer Herz-Katete operiert?
Ja, ich hatte mal eine Knie-OP,
weil ich einen Kreuzband-Riss hatte,
aber das ist schon lange her.
Rechts oder links?
Rechts, nach einem Sportunfall.
Ansonsten habe ich eine Leistenherne,
die ist mir operiert worden, auf der linken Seite.
Und ja, als Kinder haben und die Mandeln sind raus.
Mandeln, mhm.
Wann war das?
Als Kind.
Und leisten, Herr OP, wann war das?
Das war vor sieben Jahren.
Vor sieben Jahren.
Ja.
Solch fand Fris, wann haben Sie bekommen?
Und da war ich noch Student, also mit 25 Jahren, glaube ich.
Und 20, okay.
Ja.
Leider sind sie ungewöhnlichen, allergen,
oder unverträglich, Karten?
Also, der ist nichts bekannt, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Regal-Mesik oder?
Was wollen Sie jetzt damit sagen?
Ob ich Alkohol bin oder was?
Trinken Sie, ich meine, Trinken Sie Alkohol, Regal-Mesik
Ja, glauben Sie, weil Sie Türken sind und keine Alkohol trinken,
dass Sie auch kein Alkohol trinken darf oder was?
Was interessiert Sie denn?
Was interessiert Sie, ob ich Alkohol trinke oder nicht, Frau Drokta?
Das ist wichtig für Ihre Lebensgewohnheit. Wir müssen alles fragen.
Nein, ich werde da auch nicht antworten.
Hat Sie doch nicht interessieren, ob ich jetzt Alkohol trinke oder nicht?
Ich bin hier wegen Schmerzen und Sie fragen mich nach Alkohol.
Wollen Sie mir fragen, ob ich Alkohol krank oder was?
Ich möchte Ihren Oberarzt sprechen, bitte.
Ja, Herr Fischer, ich würde gerne Ihn helfen.
Ich frage diese Frau, die Sie haben,
dass Sie sich nicht mehr über die Alkohol trinken,
aber Sie haben sich nicht mehr über die Alkohol trinken.
Ich würde gerne Ihn helfen.
Ich frage diese Frau,
weil ich über alle Systemen Informationen bekomme.
Ich werde da auch nicht antworten.
Okay, vielleicht später.
Und rauchen Sie?
Das fragt mich auch jeder, meine Güte.
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel rauchen Sie?
Rauchen Sie Zigaretten.
Ich rauche ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag.
Zeigbar?
Jetzt wollen Sie auch noch wissen, seit wann?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage über die Alkohol trinken.
Ich bin jetzt da.
Meine Gott, wollen Sie mich nicht untersuchen?
Natürlich, ich werde Sie untersuchen.
Aber ich brauche jede Frage.
Ich brauche nur wenig Zeit.
Meine Güte.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich gehe nach Hause.
Das dauert viel zu lange.
Ja, Sie haben recht, aber ich muss alles erfahren.
Das ist sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich bin da,
aber ich habe noch eine Frage.
Sie sollen mir wegen meinen Schmerzen helfen.
Nicht über meine Rauche und Alkohol fragen.
Meine Güte.
Nehmen Sie, haben Sie einfach eine Droge?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Meine Güte, Sie haben eine Droge?
Ich bin jetzt ein Drogen-Dealer.
Ich frage mich nicht, ob ich Sie nicht antworten würde.
Ich frage mich nicht, ob Sie nicht antworten würden.
Aber Herr Fischer, ich hatte noch ein paar Fragen.
Sie stellen immer eine Frage.
Ich will Antworten, Frau Doktor.
Ich will Antworten auf meine Beschwerden.
Ich werde Ihre Probleme eine Lösung finden.
Aber natürlich.
Aber nur ein wenig Zeit.
Ich habe noch ein wenig Zeit.
Ich habe nur ein wenig Zeit geduft.
Wie viel noch?
Ich sitze seit halb- bis halb-Stunden über Fragen.
Sie haben vielleicht recht, aber ich muss diese Fragen stellen.
Aber nur ganz wenige Fragen.
Das ist meine Aufgabe.
Ansonsten gehe ich.
Ich würde gerne auch ein bisschen
vielleicht Ihre Frage stellen.
Ich würde gerne auch ein bisschen vielleicht Ihre Vater oder Ihre Leider.
Sie können an einem wichtigen Erfragung leiden.
Und natürlich, das kann Ihnen beeinflussen.
Deswegen musste ich auch diese Frage stellen.
Leidung Ihrer Eltern an irgendeinem Verschirm für Erfragungen?
Also mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich weiß nicht, was diese Frage ist.
Was es mit mir zu tun hatte.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es mit mir zu tun hatte.
Mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Er ist vor 3 Jahren verstorben.
5 Jahre.
Vor 3 Jahren.
Meine Mutter hatte einen Schlagan-Strag.
Sie haben ungefähr 7 Jahre verstorben.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein.
Was machen Sie?
Ich bin Mezgermeister.
Wie sind Sie?
Ich kann leider nicht.
Ich kann Sie ein bisschen erklären.
Mezgermeister ist ein schlachter Tier.
Ein Schaf, ein Rind.
Ein kleinerer Fleisch.
Ich mache Wurst.
Ein Fleisch.
Essen Sie Fleisch?
Ja, ich esse Fleisch.
Aber ich versuche wenig.
Fleisch ist im Maleka.
Aber ich versuche wenig zu essen.
Schweinefleisch?
Ja.
Ich versuche wenig zu essen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sagen Sie vielleicht, dass Sie kein Schweinefleisch essen.
Ja.
Also, jetzt ist es genug, oder?
Ja, aber ich habe es gesagt, dass Sie mit einer Krankung zu tun.
Ja, aber ich habe es gesagt, dass Sie kein Schweinefleisch essen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin verheiratet.
Frau Doktor, noch mal fragen.
Ja, ich habe eine Sohn und eine Tochter.
Ja, sind Sie gesund?
Gott sei Dank.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Jetzt ist Frau Doktor.
Ich möchte, dass Sie mich untersuchen und sagen, was ist das?
Ja, jetzt werde ich die Köpfer unterhalten.
Oder?
Ja, vielleicht, einige Bilder,
mir geben das Fahrfahren und brauche ich vielleicht eine Rundke-Nau-Fnahme.
Ja, nachdem ich untersuchen kann,
werden wir wieder mit Ihnen sprechen.
Nehmen Sie mir auch Blut ab?
Ja, ja, ja, wir nehmen auch Blut.
Wenn Sie Ihre Sachen nicht verstehen, dann rufen Sie Ihren Oberarzt.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Und nachdem ich untersuchen kann,
werden wir wieder mit Ihnen darüber sprechen.
Dann hoffe ich, dass ich bald die Ergebnisse komme.
Alles klar.
Okay, wo soll ich warten?
Soll ich irgendwo in einem Zimmer?
Ja, ja, ja. Wir haben ein Wartesimmer.
Wie setzen Sie sich und ich rufen Sie auf?
Lasst Sie mich nicht lange warten, Frau Doktor.
Nein, Sie warten, ist doch lange.
Okay.
Danke für Ihre Geburtsjahre.
Danke, Frau Doktor.
Guten Tag.
Ich bedanke mich, ich regeduld und verschaue mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich hoffe, dass Sie mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Sie haben gesagt, Hausarzt und orthopedische Arzt
besucht, welche Untersuchungen durchgeführt wurden.
Hausarzt und orthopedische.
Hausarzt hat gesagt, er weiß es nicht,
kann nichts machen und er hat noch ein bisschen Blut abgenommen,
sagt, der findet nichts, hat mich zum Orthopäen geschickt,
er hat mal eine Röntgenaufnahme gemacht.
Er sagt auch, er sieht da nichts.
Deswegen bin ich nicht mehr da,
ich habe nichts und deswegen bin ich jetzt ins Klagen rausgekommen.
Früher diese Beschwerden schon einmal?
Nein, habe ich nicht mehr.
Also wie gesagt, das hatte ich jetzt erst seit 3 Monaten.
Dann habe ich jetzt seit 3 Monaten.
Erstens, können wir anfangen, bitte?
Ja.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen Patient,
hätte Sie dafür gesagt, ich möchte Sie ihn vorstellen.
Dann stellen Sie mal vor.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie den Patienten diesmal gut untersuchen können.
Ich versuche zu machen.
Er ist 67 Jahre alt.
Er ist 75 Jahre alt.
Und 102 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hat Schmerzen,
seit 3 Monaten,
in dem linken,
wirbel Bereich.
Und ich bitte, können Sie das genau schildern?
Ja, in dem länden Bereich.
London, ja, länden Bereich, ok, alles klar.
Ich habe ein bisschen besser Ausdrucken, Frau Doktor, ich verstehe Sie kaum.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen würden in den beiden Beinen ausstreifen.
Und bei ihm, er hat diese Schmerzen,
bei ihm Bewegung auch in Ruhe.
Und die Schmerzen haben sich im Verlauf verschlimmert.
Okay.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist
kramfartig unthumpf.
Auf einer Schmerzskala legen die Schmerzen
bei 7 und 8.
Manchmal leitet er auf
eine andere Art und Art.
Und Kraftlosigkeit,
und die Extremität.
Und die Frage,
nach weiterer Beschwerde,
würde ich Sie sagen.
Anfallerfrankungen,
Leiderer, Arterien,
über 20 Jahre,
und auch die Parkolistinämie vor drei Jahren.
Und er wurde mit einem Stand behandelt.
Wo ist der Stand?
Herzkatheter.
Er hat einen Herzgefäßen.
Welches Gefäß ist da dilatiert worden?
Haben Sie da einen Befund?
Ja, ich habe den Herzgefäßen angefordert.
Oder haben Sie da hat der Patient etwas mitgebracht?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestalt.
Ich werde unterhalten.
Wie oft muss ich Ihnen das sagen?
Wenn der Patient seine vorherigen Berichte anfordern,
dann muss ich das alles vorliegen haben.
Sie müssen bei seinem Hausarzt anrufen.
Oder bei seinem Facharzt,
dass Sie die ganzen Brüfe schicken.
Haben Sie das gemacht?
Nein, ich habe das gemacht,
aber habe ich leider nicht bekommen.
Ach so.
Das heißt,
dass er dann auch eine KKK hatte.
Was heißt, die Leicht hatte es oder hatte es nicht?
Wenn der Patient den Herzkatheter hatte,
oder einen Stand in einem Gefäß bekommen hatte,
dann hatte er eine Coronahre herzgekommen.
Das sind eine KKK.
Coronahre herzerkampeln,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob die Menschen von der Gefäße betroffen sind.
Okay, das wartet mir den Befund ab,
aber er hatte eine KKK.
Ja, er nehme Regalmistik,
Amlodipin, 50 mg,
Meins, Metaprolol, 50 mg,
Abund und Morgan,
kann wir starten.
16 mg,
nur einmal Abund
und Atorvastatin,
80 mg, nur abund.
Das ist eine KKK,
so ist es 80 mg.
Ja,
und er hatte Knieopie
recht wegen einem
Kreuzpanzlis mit 5 mg,
und er wurde
linken,
in die
Kreuzpanzlung.
Ja,
sein Vater hat
am Yokarta,
infarkt, gelitten,
und er ist daran
für die Jahre gestorben.
Sein Mutter hatte Apoplex
und für die Jahre gestorben.
Er ist
meist im Semester,
und verheiratet.
Er hatte
einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Er
hatte ungefähr
20,
seit 20 Jahren
und
ich habe über
Alkoholkonsum und
Dropkonsum gefragt,
aber der Patient möchte nicht
darüber mehr sprechen,
und diese Frage nicht
beantwortet.
Dann
ich
frage mich,
warum ist er da?
Das ist eine somatische Schmerzen,
aber andererseits
habe ich andere Verdacht,
die Agnose, das ist eine Diskus-Karne.
Eine, was?
Diskus-Karne
im Landenbereich.
Bandscheinvorfall, meinen Sie?
Ja, Bandscheinvorfall.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Muss ich erst korprärische
Untersuchungen auch durchführen?
Woran denken Sie noch?
Ich denke, dass die
Pheranze die Agnose
ist.
Vielleicht
die Fibromyalgie
und ja auch
die Fibromyalgie.
Die Fibromyalgie
vielleicht auch.
Die Ärzte sind von
Gelenk zu Gelenk gesprungen.
Deswegen habe ich das gedacht.
Was ist noch eine Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, es könnte
auch Pina Stenosa sein.
Stenose von was?
Stone, Lumball,
wie soll Stenose sein?
Ach Sie meinen Spinalkanal-Stenose?
Ja, Spinalkanal-Stenose sein.
Ja, gut.
Was brauchen Sie da für eine Untersuchung um festzustellen?
Ja, dann werde ich erst
Doktor stoppen.
Beantworten Sie meine Frage.
Welche Untersuchungen brauchen Sie
für eine Diagnose?
Ich brauche ja
eine MRT
oder ein CT.
Aber erst werde ich
Röntgen-Torax aufnahme.
Veranlasst es?
Also das ist eine Röntgenaufnahme nicht vom Torax,
sondern von der Wirbelsäule.
Wirbelsäule, ja.
Sie müssen sich schon genau ausdrücken,
Doktor, was Sie wollen.
Das ist wichtig in der Medizin.
Nicht wischewasche, sondern genau, was Sie wollen.
Sie müssen es richtig beschreiben.
Ich werde auch als
Blutuntersuchungen, Blutfilms,
Blutstenkunggeschwindigkeit
und Romatischerkrankungen sein.
Welche Werte kontrollieren Sie bei den Muskelschmerzen?
Rheumafaktor,
Blutstenkunggeschwindigkeit,
Blutfilms,
Bezwerbsbeschmerz.
Sie denken auch, eine Rheumaferkrankung?
Sie denken auch, eine Rheumaferkrankung.
Ja.
Kann Sie machen?
Das ist etwas teuer.
Wir machen eine Ausnahme.
Welche Werte nehmen Sie noch?
Vielleicht ZEKA.
Ja, genau.
ZEKA
Ich glaube, das ist genug.
Vielleicht ja.
Wir fragen mal den anderen Kollegen.
Da gab es ja einige Ideen schon.
Was es sein könnte.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Sind Sie schon Fachärztin?
Ja, ich bin Fachärztin.
Ich bin eine Kulogin.
Dann ist es zu viel zu Sie heute gewesen.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Ich habe sehr gute Schmerzen bekommen.
Da sind Schmerzen im Bereich von Rücken,
in den Armen, in den Beinen.
Ich habe sogar einen jungen Mann,
der hat Albträume,
der hat Depressionen bekommen.
Ich habe auch eine andere Frau,
die hat Albträume,
der hat Depressionen bekommen.
Auf ganz niedrig dosierte CSE-Kolesterinsenker.
Da muss man immer wieder dran denken,
dass Patienten die Medikamente
gegen Kolesterin nehmen,
dass sie solche Nebenwirkungen bekommen können.
Da haben wir diesen Test.
Ich weiß nicht, wer das war.
Wir sind alle Doktorin.
Ich bin Lungenärztin.
Ja.
Auch ein Internistin.
Das ist richtig.
Man muss auch die Diagnose bewegen.
Man muss die Diagnose bewegen.
Man muss die Diagnose beberishen.
Man muss die Diagnose be Wallace Huth,
jede Diagnose beimetersen.
Man muss die Diagnose beownerspaрядlikten.
Sagt!?
Das ist keine Fibromyalgie.
Die ist ganz was anderes.
Die ist eine Clear Stevee,
eineclear Stevee mit Blutfeld.
angucken, Blut fehlt. Manchmal ist die ZK erhöht, aber sehr oft aber auch nicht.
Da lässt man einfach, was macht man da? Man hört auf mit den Atorvastatin und sehr
schnell innerhalb von wenigen Tagen sind die Patienten beschwerterfrei.
Und achten wir darauf, der Laborwerte der Laborwerte.
Und auf die Laborwerte, genau. Ja, und was macht man, Herr Doktor, wenn Sie jetzt
auf Atorvastatin so reagieren, aber Sie brauchen jetzt Kohlesterinsenker wegen KHAK.
Was gibt man dann, Herr Doktor Gündig?
Erstmal weniger Dose und andere Kohlesterinsenker, zum Beispiel.
Nach Atorvastatin?
Atorvastatin nicht.
Also der Patient hatte schon Symmastatin.
Ja, genau.
Rosavastatin, Rosavastatin vielleicht.
Genau, Rosavastatin kann man probieren.
Und es gibt ECT-MIP.
Genau, das kann man auch mal probieren.
Es gibt heutzutage auch in der Zwischenzeit neuere Medikamente, die man als
Spritzen, Pravastatin wäre auch eine Option, genau.
Da sind alles jetzt Kohlesterinsenker.
In der Zwischenzeit heute auch andere Biologiker heißen die, glaube ich,
wo man als Spritze, als subkultare Spritze gibt, einmal die Woche oder alle zwei Wochen
oder einmal im Monat. Die sind sehr, sehr teuer, aber die wirken sehr effektiv.
Es gibt es in der Zwischenzeit auch sehr gut.
Genau, eine Differenzialdiagnose haben wir vergessen, das war sehr gut.
Und die Arteriosen natürlich, würde Schilderosenwerte können natürlich auch
solche Myoprätin auslösen.
Oder Hyperparateroide wegen...
Also eine endocrine Schwörung, natürlich den Haushalt
durcheinander bringen und natürlich auch solche Beschwerden machen.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Sehr gut.
Wir haben auch einige Internisten unter uns.
Das ist sehr schön.
So, guck mal, wie viel haben wir? 20, sehr gut.